qu'est ce que c'est vrai là il est en
train de rappeler un truc c'est vraiment
génial c'est il ya trois quatre ans où
ben autour d'un verre en discutait et
puis je disais que tu sais j'ai repris
la musique moi comme ça on a une
conversation amicale il dit avant
j'espère que ça va marcher géante si je
fais vraiment ça pour m'amuser je pense
pas du tout que ça marchera mais en tout
cas je m'éclate je vais au studio toutes
les semaines ça un peu marcher bah ça
marche très bien
moi je viens juste d'apprendre que les
auteurs des guignols drogba depuis des
années une coucherie david pourquoi tu
as fait des jockeys n'avait pas le
physique pour être poète videurs en fait
je suis arrivé je suis arrivé vraiment
dans la nuit par la musique moi j'ai
commencé mon premier job de djs et quand
j'avais 17 ans et j'ai jamais fréquenté
les clubs pour draguer ou pour sortir
avec des copains ou ou ni même vraiment
pour danser d'ailleurs j'ai toujours je
suis toujours à l'inter pour mixer parce
que depuis que j'ai 14 ans j'achète des
disques et à part la drogue tu prends
quoi pour tenir ce rythme tout à l'heure
super il en reste ils commencent à être
tape tout est tout à leur maquillage à
ma faim une petite erreur de parcours
j'avais plein de poudre blanche en bas
du neige
ouais non non c'est comme moi c'est quoi
ton secret d'un ben justement c'est pas
de drogue
l'amour un thé pas de drogue ces dames
et l'amour ouais tu vas jamais vu la
lumière du jour cathy paraît c'est vrai
tu vas mal dans sa soute
quelques passes ta vie dans les bois tu
vas ou quand tu veux t'amuser en ce
moment je vais en angleterre tous les
week-end et je m'éclate
voilà veux bien croire et david guetta
et je le dis et je sais que ça va me
coûter très cher demain dans le quartier
mais il est beaucoup plus simple de g
que 90% des rappeurs la technologie mais
j'assume mais il le doit à bondy je
crois qu'on va rester là dessus parce
que ça c'est quand même un très beau
compliment
enfin se blesse